next author and journalist jim mars
discusses his book rule by secrecy the
hidden history that connects the
trilateral commission the freemasons and
the great pyramids the book is about
these organizations and mars opinions of
their influence on social and political
life mr mars discussed themes from his
book on a recent broadcast of the bob
grant show a call-in radio program from
the wor radio studios in new york city
[Music]
and uh let's be heard we continue the
bob grant program coast to coast border
to border often imitated never
duplicated
here we are in round three of our
get-together and as promised
we do have jim mars with us
who has authored rule by secrecy
the
hidden history
that connects the trilateral commission
the freemasons
and the great pyramids
and what intrigues me about having mr
mars here as a guest and talking about
this particular book
is over the years in doing the bob grant
radio program
i have gotten telephone calls
intermittently but nevertheless
consistently
from people who talk about the
trilateral commission
in these sinister tones
uh let's find out first of all who jim
mars is he's described by his publisher
harpercollins
as a
celebrated journalist
and the author of alien agenda
and the new york times bestseller
crossfire
and uh you uh live in texas uh mr mars
how long have you been working on this
book
well i guess it's safe to be
to say that i've been working on it most
of my professional life in fact i wish
that i had this book about 25 years ago
or so when i first heard of the
trilateral commission and the council on
foreign relations and
bilderbergers and i like probably a lot
of your audience was wondering well
number one do these things really exist
and number two do they really have any
power well the trouble uh
the trouble is as i see it
people call the program and um they talk
uh as though um
it's it's absolutely fearsome are you
afraid of this uh conglomeration uh this
conspiracy as you put it well not
particularly because uh anything that
has to operate in secrecy uh can be
exposed by the light of knowledge and
media attention all right let's do some
exposure here and give it the media
attention who are these people are they
connected
yes
we'll just go backwards we've got the
bilderbergers which is so secret that
they don't even have a name that was
named after the hotel bilderberg where
they were first found to be meeting
annually back in 1954
they are the inner circle
of cross membership with the trilateral
commission which was founded in 1972 by
david rockefeller and seven other
members of the even more secretive
council on foreign relations
and they were both offshoots of the
cecil rhodes round tables which was a
secret organization taking place back
before world war one
and of course cecil rhodes not only left
money to found these secret societies as
he himself stated in his will but of
course he left money for the rhodes
scholarship of which bill clinton our
president was one of them
um is this the same cecil rhodes uh
named
uh for which rhodesia was named i
believe so he was the diamond magnate of
africa now
zimbabwe what's the point of this
organization what are they after well
first let's let's uh i call them secret
societies because you and i can't walk
in off the street become a member and by
their own bylaws and guidelines and
regulations they're not supposed to talk
about what they discuss in their
meetings so it's pretty secret but
actually it's not that secret they're in
the phone book they have a office right
here in new york uh
so does the trilateral commission
their agenda is not all that secret
either they are pushing for
globalization which is a one world
military one world government one world
political system one world economy one
world monetary system
and uh in fact uh i would quote from
strobe talbert who is president
clinton's deputy secretary of state uh
back in 92 he told time magazine in the
next century
meaning today
nations as we know it will be obsolete
all states will recognize a single
global authority
national sovereignty wasn't such a great
idea after all
i know that strobe talbot said that
and i have read that quote elsewhere
but how do you tie that in with this
trilateral commission
well strobe talbert is a big member of
the council on foreign relations i don't
know if he's a member of the trilateral
commission or not but i thought that was
a pretty straightforward vocalization of
of their game plan they want this one
world government one world military uh
and i'm not i'm not a real reactionary
i'm not even going to try to say that oh
this is terrible you know you ask me if
i'm afraid of it i'm not sure but i have
some questions because number one
if this total one world or government or
the new world order as people have
called it if if that's such a good thing
if that's the path to peace and
prosperity then why is it so secretive
why are they manipulating in the shadows
why are they pushing this agenda through
organizations like the world trade
organization and i like that and and
that leads of course to my basic
question which is if they attain a one
world government a one-world order
what is our guarantee that some new
hitler-like tyrant won't gain control
over that
well we don't have a guarantee in any
event even if we don't have a one-world
government look what uh this president
has been doing with all his executive
orders with people being audited
if they um
uh complained that they were raped by
the president that's right and
where does this president come from he
comes right out of the council on
foreign relations in the build of
burgers even hillary clinton has been
the first american first lady to attend
a bilderberger meeting so they they are
in integratedly into intertwined with
this new world order and that's what i'm
saying they're pushing it not through
laws enacted by our elected
representatives but through trade
agreements and presidential
orders all right you know there's so
much to cover here and i certainly don't
want to leave our audience out of this
by the way you folks
you can start calling i guarantee you
i'm not going to hog mr mars all to
myself although i have
uh
hundreds of questions that uh are
dancing through my mind right now why do
you uh
why do you link the trilateral
commission
with the freemasons
well because the trilateral commission
uh as i said is clearly an offshoot of
the council on foreign relations which
was again created uh by the the people
that were members of cecil rhodes
roundtables and they were all freemasons
in fact they were illuminated freemasons
what is a freemason you know a lot of
people hear the word
and they really don't know could you
give us a definition of what a freemason
is well
i i think there are probably as many
definitions of freemasonry as there are
freemasons but what i can tell you is
that the freemasons
um
uh were the creations and stem from the
old stone mason gills back during the
middle ages and they were created by
another secret society the world's first
and foremost the illuminati no the
knights templar
tonight's templar right
now the illuminati came along in the
1700s and their game plan was a
graduated income tax a a destruction of
all religion and of all uh states nation
states all like that in fact their
platform read very very similarly to the
communist manifesto that was published
in the mid-1800s by karl marx true or
false mr mars uh many of our founding
fathers were freemasons true george
washington was uh was a
leading uh freemason in fact the in
freemasonry uh text and writings they
claim that the boston tea party was
actually conducted by masons who had
just left a masonic meeting at the
temple there in boston and what do
freemasons believe or don't you know
well that's what i discuss in my new
book rule by secrecy and there's a lot
of controversy about that because for
one thing according to masonic authors
and historians there are circles within
circles there is an outer circle of
freemasons who uh probably are in there
for the most noble of purposes and and
there's no question that they do a lot
of philanthropic good their burn centers
are world renown
but within that there's an inner circle
that has perhaps another agenda but
we'll never really learn about that
because the outer circle is unaware that
the inner circle exists and the inner
circle is pledged to an oath that they
will never reveal so if you ask a mason
is there an inner circle he will tell
you no
mr mars i mean no disrespect and you
seem like a delightful knowledgeable uh
individual you certainly speak very well
no disrespect intended but somehow
rather i feel as though i'm in a in a an
episode of the x-files
well uh you know i've heard that the
x-files has been said to be the best
documentary on television
um it's i'll i'll have to admit that for
years as a as a print journalist i had
severe doubts and questions about all of
this you know are there really secret
groups do they really plot to try to
talk about circles within circles within
circles i mean it's well i'm simply in
my book i i it's not my conspiracy
theory i quote from uh the
masonic historians themselves and they
all it freely admit to that
ladies and gentlemen if you've just
tuned in we're talking to jim mars who
touches on a subject that many callers
of the bob grant program over the years
have
uh suggested without perhaps having uh
the
knowledge that our guest obviously has
and if you want to join in it's very
easy you don't have to come
running down to the studio all you have
to do is pick up the telephone dial
after our 1-800-321-8828-1-800-321-8828
quick break coming up
i want to ask our guest jim mars
what
he
means when he includes
the great pyramids as part of this great
mystery straight ahead
[Music]
i promise i won't keep it
was it only on the one or the five just
on the one this other one oh the pyramid
yeah i don't know
okay have you got a one yeah
thank you
and there we go
you two gentlemen have no idea when this
will be shown
it is brian lamb gonna let us know when
he shows this roy
is brian lamb gonna let us know when he
shows this
uh
our boys there will let us know
with no computer expertise you can now
own your own internet business part-time
if you wish full-time if you want where
you not just the computer experts can
make money on the world widely
fortune time and entrepreneur magazine
all state this is the hot business for
the new millennium imagine a business
where you need no employees no inventory
not even an office virtually no overhead
yet you can make hundreds even thousands
of dollars a week
for the rest of your life call netspace
at
1-800-439-1004 now for your free
information package to see if you can
profit from the internet
1-800-439-1004 we can get you started on
the business of the next adventure call
now 1-800-439-1004
there's no cost or obligation the future
is now 1-800-439-1004
who has time to
automatically
they even pick the destinations ahead of
time it's called farewatcher from
travelocity.com it automatically sends
you email updates there are fares to the
destinations you're looking for yeah
that travelocity.com the most powerful
reservation system on the planet over 40
000 hotel properties 95 of all the
world's airline seats and over 50 rental
cars
even has problems finding a parking
space most days but there is one thing
joe doesn't have problems with his skin
joe
you see uses skin cleanser is ph
balanced it gently reclaims dirt and oil
to prevent problems whether your skin is
dry oily or sensitive
no problem
nascar driver dine talks about gold
medals
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing i mentioned
is directed
ladies and gentlemen bob grant here and
our guest is jim mars
he is a journalist he is an author
he has uh written a book which has just
been published by harper collins called
rule by secrecy subtitle
the hidden history
that connects the trilateral commission
the freemasons
and the great pyramids all right now
what about the great pyramids yeah how
does that fit in
well just to show that we're not talking
about something that has no connection
to all of us i would uh just simply say
that all your listeners all have to do
is pull a dollar bill out of their
pocket look on the reverse side and
you'll see the great seal of the united
states and it has a pyramid on it with
the all-seeing eye of knowledge at the
top and under in latin it says novus
ordo seclorum which can be translated is
new world order and that's because
america was a new world order from the
uh from the
royal systems of
europe and these are the same people who
are now pushing for the new world order
of today and the connection to the great
pyramid is simply uh through the secret
societies which
the information has been passed through
free masonry and back to the knights
templar
who discovered the writings under the
temple of solomon in jerusalem back at
the time of the first crusade
which takes us back to the ancient
mysteries of greece and egypt and that's
why the pyramid is on there representing
uh not only the ancient mysteries but
the fact that the eye of all seeing
knowledge is at the top of a pyramid of
power which means that within these
secret societies there are a an elite
who have this ancient mystery in this
ancient knowledge and what is that well
walter willemhurst who is a masonic uh
author and historian
said that
once men
were
taught and guided by the gods
okay
and that another one mainly p hall who
was a ranking mason he has expounded on
that a little bit he said in the remote
past the gods
walked with men and they chose from
among the sons of men the wisest and the
truest and these illumined ones founded
what we know as the ancient mysteries
what does all this have to do with the
year 2000 and
why we should be concerned about the
trilateral commission the cfr
the bilderbergers you know uh and again
this is not meant as criticism now you
know that's literally the fact the
matter is most americans
didn't study history they hated history
i was i was considered an oddball
because that was my favorite subject but
you cover so much here you're talking
about the french revolution you talk
about the jacobins
and you're also talking about the
protocols of zion which is uh
usually trotted out by anti-semites
that's true that's that particular book
has probably caused more problems than
nearly any other book in history and
let's quickly put this to rest
the protocols of elders of zion was a
remake of early of an earlier text which
was remade before world war one by the
uh czar's secret police to try to make
it look like that the revolution that
was then brewing in russia was the
result of some sort of international
jewish conspiracy and there are still
those today who adhere to that idea but
it's nonsense because you cannot ascribe
any worldwide plot to a group of people
that would be like saying hitler and the
nazis was some sort of white plot
and yet you're saying that uh what
you're talking about in your book is a
worldwide plot
but it's a plot by people who transcend
races or groups of people or businesses
or anything
they have in common the desire that's
been here since the beginning of time
which is to basically control the world
now some people would say oh that's
negative and some people say well that's
positive perhaps we need somebody to
continue you know you know the way
things are going in the united states of
america i'm beginning to think that way
myself let's take a phone call because
we've got so many people waiting wanting
to talk to you and uh let's open up
pandora's box right now paul in the car
go right ahead for jim mars
bob i want to i'm a freemason and i just
want to
give you four sentences that tell you
what a mason is for your for your
listeners who who are listening to this
hogwash
okay
by the way they're also seeing it
because this is going to be shown on
c-span oh wonderful
every freemason asserts his belief in
god and the immortality of the soul
believes that how he worships god is his
own business
therefore he believes fervently in
freedom of religion
is aware that religion and politics are
often used to drive men apart
they may not be discussed in any masonic
lodge
and he never puts his duties and
responsibilities to masonry ahead of his
duties and responsibilities to his god
to his family or to his country all
right that's what masonry is all about
all right now what do you what do you
say to that jim mars that doesn't sound
ominous no it doesn't and in fact again
let me make the point that i think the
great majority of masons are honest
well-meaning well-intentioned people but
if you go back and really study your
history you'll find that the jocobites
were the people who wanted to put james
the first back onto the throne of
england and that it was freemasonry that
was used as a political weapon to try to
accomplish that end i'd also again quote
from
masonic author uh willemhurst who wrote
the meaning of masonry and he said the
meaning of masonry is a subject usually
left entirely unexpounded and that
accordingly remains largely unrealized
by its members save such few as make it
their private study
i take another call very quickly ernie
in the car go right ahead with jim mars
yeah i'd like to ask you a question
wasn't it one time if you were roman
catholic and join the masonic order you
excommunicated is that true that is true
and that was because that the beginning
of freemasonry again originated with the
knights templars uh the world's first
giant multinational corporation that
became so powerful that they
were exterminated or at least they were
tried to be exterminated by the roman
church
yeah but then didn't they we send that
later on yes he is you're not going to
be uh excommunicated now so i'll see you
at the lodge meeting tonight
okay
all right uh
let's see i don't think we have time to
take another call uh before our next
break we're talking to
jim mars author of rule by secrecy
the questions are asked uh how much do
you know about the freemasons the
trilateral commission or skull and bones
we haven't heard about that yet
did you know that both presidential
candidates al labor gore george w bush
have ties to secret societies
and more shockingly are you aware that
these secret societies manipulate stock
markets and interest rates maintain
class distinction and exercise
censorship over the media corporations
they control
hey i want to join this outfit
hey i'm missing out
no wonder i haven't done well
where do i sign up jim give me that uh
give me that application blank no you
have to be invited
[Music]
big time
i like it i'm with you
let me in
when jimmy carter was elected
i was getting phone calls
saying that the
trilateral commission put him in yup
they did
let me tell you something i interviewed
bert lance remember his economic advisor
who got in some trouble and was bounced
and i asked bert lance about the
trilateral commission and you know what
he said he looked at me and he grinned
and he said i was the only cabinet
member that was not a member and he
grinned and he said and i'm out
yeah
as bert lance said that
i kind of felt sorry for bert lance he
seemed like a nice guy
he used to instruct me that way
well i think it was one of these things
where he was a banker and they you know
they got so many it's like the irs they
got so many regulations that you know if
they want you they can tag you for
something you know and then if not then
you slide
george bush still don't be on trial for
the bcci scandal but these guys got
swept under the compared to the clinton
gang now oh yes absolutely
at some point the clinton administration
will go down as the most present i said
at some point the clinton administration
would go down in history is the most
corrupt
administration we may have ever had and
by the way i'm sure you're familiar with
teapot dome you realize that al gore in
1997 engineered this largest sale of
public lands in us history yeah to
occidental petroleum and his who his dad
was on the payroll for her for years i'm
in the hammer absolutely it's another
teapot dome but there's no media today
nobody talks about it no
the media definitely is its control
there's no in my mind
i've seen enough to believe
they all not that they meet together
they don't have to be they don't have to
you just know
you know what the plan is and what
you're supposed to say and not say
that's right that's i come from the
media i saw it operation too you know
that's why i like c-span because they
put the camera on
and the people aren't hearing
distorting narration
right
that's one of our big hopes then the
internet
of course with the internet the upside
is is that everybody and anybody has
access and the downside is that anybody
and everybody has access
you don't know who to listen to you know
are you getting uh
let's see i i see uh that uh tomorrow
you go to uh washington you're gonna be
on uh what program in washington uh i'm
i'm not sure i've been traveling so fast
and furious i'm just kind of into days
but uh the the reception though
surprisingly has been very positive i
think people are beginning to say you
know maybe we need to at least take a
look at this and find out columns is
pushing this
they published sometimes
are on their own you know no no this is
harper
collins but you know uh after the uh
after everybody finally kind of figured
out uh after world war ii that it was
not an international jewish conspiracy
they could still see the footprints
though of conspiracy taking place so it
shifted then to the international
communist conspiracy
[Music]
rule by secrecy is the uh name of the
book jim mars is the author he's sitting
right here with me on the bob grant
program
and uh we've got calls coming in from
all over let's go to uh bob checking in
bob from thornwood go right ahead bob
hello bob yes sir hey bob don't you
think it would be fair if you told the
gentleman that uh your father is a mason
and that you're quite knowledgeable and
i've heard you speak very eloquently in
defense of the masons
well i i think the gentleman should know
that well you know there's no there's no
big secret here my father was a mason
he's uh
shuffled off this mortal coil quite a
long time ago
well just for the record my father was a
mason and my grandfather was a mason
when i'm not trying to attack the masons
i've already said three times i'll say
it again most masons the vast majority
of masons in this country are good
honest honorable people trying to do the
best they can for their country
i understand but uh
listening as i am now
you would think that bob had very little
knowledge of
masonry
and in another broadcast about a year
ago bob was very very knowledgeable
about things pertaining to masonry well
i wasn't interviewing jim mars who's
written a book
and uh who includes freemasonry in
the connection with the trilateral
commission and uh the
other organizations like the cfr
uh you want me to interview myself
tomorrow i'll interview myself how's
that oh bob i'm a real fan you do very
well thank you very much mom
okay
let's say hello to you know what amazes
me i want to share this with you because
i think you have an appreciation for
this i tell the audience things i tell
them things that they would not know
otherwise and then months or years later
they will say why don't you tell the guy
that like i've been trying to keep it a
secret you know
okay let's say hello to dan from
manhattan go ahead dan hi bob yes how
are you doing all right i guess i know
you hate to hear that
um i have a question for your guest i've
read a little bit of the literature in
this conspiratorial genre
and one of my big issues with it is that
people write these kinds of books they
tend to
use other
writers in this field as footnotes
there's no real primary sources
for any of this stuff
and a lot of these books can be traced
back to one book
and the name of the book is called
tragedy and hope
by
carol quigley
who happened to be bill clinton's mentor
at georgetown
and i was wondering if your guest could
speak a little bit about quigley
yes i'd be glad to and by the way i
consulted more than 300 separate sources
in writing rule by secrecy and i tried
to go with the ones that i felt like
were the most credible and substantial
sources admittedly there's a lot of
flaky writing out there about
conspiracies okay you have to weigh your
way through it dr carol quigley on the
other hand i think is a credible source
uh he was with uh george washington
university as you said he was the mentor
academic mentor to to bill clinton and
he himself writes about the secret
societies and he writes about how that
the the royal institute of international
affair and the and the council on
foreign relations were the two branches
that were created from the round tables
and he lays bare what they had and he
says because he had knowledge of their
inner workings because he had access to
their working papers in fact what he
actually said was
that he really doesn't have any real
objection to this globalization program
of theirs the only place he parted
difference with the secret societies is
that he thought that they were doing
such spectacular work that they needed
to be known to the public and they
wanted to remain secret
right but if you remember
a lot of a lot of uh writers who use
quickly as a source take him out of
context well it's not out of context you
can go to tragedy and hope or he also
wrote a a companion piece about the
history of the world and he goes on for
several pages about this it's not just a
few sentences pulled out of context i've
actually read both of those page 950 of
the tragedy and hope where a lot of this
comes from
quickly calls it a myth i tell you what
and
even though he's slipping me uh a few
folded uh bills under the table
uh i'm still going to tell you
that with your interest and your obvious
background here you really should get mr
mars book and by the way folks
you can get this book at a discount
you can get this book at a discount
by calling uh on your website there on
your computer the internet
www.wor710.com
i'll do that again w w w dot
you can order
uh the book at a discount if you do it
that way
uh
some uh can i can i throw in a quick let
me throw in another quote here because i
don't want people to think that i'm just
some guy that sits around dreams up
conspiracy theories uh i've done my
homework and i've checked it out and one
of the most disconcerting quotes i found
was from woodrow wilson of all peaceful
who of course was intimately connected
with the secret societies and was the
presiding president when the federal
reserve system uh was initiated as well
as the irs
and he once wrote
he said some of the biggest men in the
united states in the field of commerce
and manufacture are afraid of something
they know that there's a power somewhere
so organized so subtle so watchful so
interlocked so complete so pervasive
that they better not speak above their
breath when they speak in condemnation
of it
now that's woodrow wilson and i feel
like he's in a position to know what
he's talking about did he write that
before or after his stroke
he wrote that in 1913. that was before
his struggle yeah before his struggle
you know i read an interesting uh
perhaps revisionist uh history
that um there are many alerted
historians
who believe
that the worst thing that happened in
the 20th century all things considered
was that england entered world war one
and because they entered world war one
france was not defeated quickly by
germany kaiser's germany folks not
hitler's germany
and that had germany won world war one
there never would have been a hitler
that ever would have been in world war
ii what do you think of that well i
point this out and quote from some world
leaders that uh world war ii by most
accounts was simply an extension of
world war one
and world war one when you go back
you'll find was propagated by these very
people in these very societies that i'm
talking about now that again you early
on you asked me well you know and i hear
people all the time what's the relevance
to us today well if you had anybody in
world war one world war ii and the
effect that those wars have had on us
today then you should be interested to
know what was that all about let me take
it even further back i'm kind of a lay
historian and
a civil war buff i guess you could call
it and of course where i come from they
call it the war of uh between the states
but uh i was amazed to find that there
is evidence
that the war between states the american
civil war and in fact
otto von bismarck himself
said that the civil war in the united
states was planned years ahead of time
by the financial powers of europe and
there is substantial information which i
present in my book real by secrecy to
show that that very well could be true
i think at that point we better take a
timeout and agent smulder and scully
where are you when we need you straight
ahead
[Music]
the name of the book
they were which one the one that we're
talking about tragedy and hope
secrecy
ruled by secrecy
[Music]
have you ever heard of the uh knights of
the golden circle
what's that the knights of the golden
circle
no i never have i've heard of it yeah
well john wilkes booth was a member of
that and
i found in researching that so was sam
houston
sam history and in fact right in 1860
there were 50 000 members of the knights
of the golden circle simply in texas
this was the secret society that
basically fomented the civil war
now you mentioned uh being a civil war
buff
uh
i'm happy to tell you that
there are at last
a couple of fair books coming out about
ulysses s grant
uh
which portrays him much more fairly
well good because i i kind of feel that
way towards grant myself
even though he was a you know what
blanky blank yankee
what the heck is it
just call
1-800-220-2686 or log on to
www.freecreditreport.com
just call 1-800-220-2626
[Music]
[Music]
a great general and not a bad president
either
he knew his whiskey too
he definitely was
a good general he was a fighter john i
like lincoln's quote when uh he wanted
to appoint him the
the uh
commander of the uh union forces and the
guy says
but he drinks whiskey and lincoln says
find out what
give it to my other generals that's
right that's right
he needed somebody that would fight he
found him in grant
although grant like so many of the civil
war generals
took him a long while to get away from
those napoleonic tactics like at coal
harbor when he just kept sending frontal
attack after frontal attack you know
well they could afford to do it lee
couldn't that's right
what i like too is the quote i have in
here from abraham lincoln in 1862 that
was halfway through the war and he said
my objective is to preserve the union if
i could do that without freeing one
slave i would do it yeah if i could do
it by freeing some slaves and not others
i do right right right so this nonsense
about the civil war being fought over
slavery you know forget that there was
something else going on
that's true
time is evaporating very quickly here
with our guest jim mars author of uh
rule by secrecy let's say hello to uh
jeff in the car jeff hello hi there bob
listen i'd like to ask the author
if he could comment about these two
popular books that came out a few years
ago about
holy blood holy grail or bloodline of
the holy grail
right i thought about them yeah yeah uh
actually that's some of the sources i
consulted and what you're going to find
and i know that these these terms and
words are just going to be meaningless
to a lot of the audience but uh yes in
rule by secrecy you're going to find
that i tracked all this back through the
knights templar to the qatars to the
merovingians to the priory of scion
these are secret groups secret societies
uh alternative versions of history that
go all the way back there and in fact i
realized that a lot of what i'm saying a
lot of people are gonna take a front or
they're gonna go wait a minute because
i'm talking about information that that
most people don't get you know we're all
taught one thing and often it's another
for example uh if i was to ask where did
the name america come from uh bob do you
how how did america get its name
everyone uh every book that i've read
said it was named after uh an italian
explorer by the name of america's
vespucci that's wrong
that's right that's what i was taught
that's what you were taught that's what
most of us were taught but it's simply
not true
uh that particular version came from a
german monk by the name of martin varsi
mueller who uh back about 1507
uh managed to get hold of a printing
press he knew that there had been a new
land of america found and he had heard
of amerigo vespucius so he simply put
two and two together and said well it
was named after the great italian
navigator amerigo vest [ __ ] he later
retracted that but of course by then it
was in print and as we all know if it's
in a book it's got to be true and so
that's the kind of thing i'm talking
about we have these things that we're
taught we have these things we've heard
and what i'm trying to do is show that
there's a hidden history that a lot of
us have not heard about let's say hello
to rich from queens go ahead rich good
evening gentlemen i'm a so-called
illuminati in the rosicrucian order and
i saw that this is a mystical union with
god see one can receive revelations from
supreme through the subconscious mind
and the reason why it's secret is
because it's spiritual and not for
discussion
that's right and and i agree with the
caller that's what you find in study in
the background in the history of the
erosion crucians and
of the illuminati they uh they basically
can be tracked back to the early
gnostics who said they received all of
their knowledge directly from god
thank you very much rich let's say hello
to mark in new haven checking in right
now on the bob grant program what's on
your mind mark good afternoon gentlemen
uh i'd just like to say uh jim i think
you're right on target about what you're
talking about in your book
uh and it's very valid
and there's there's a lot of truth in
what you're saying
and i just want to also say that
i think
hillary clinton is the next antichrist
well i'm not going to stick my neck out
on that one but i will give you a little
factoid
hillary clinton is the first american
first lady who has attended bilderberg
meetings which is one of the most
secretive secret societies going and the
ones who is composed of the inner circle
of these other secret societies and the
ones who most people point to is making
the decisions that are affecting the uh
the path of the world progress thank you
very much mark let's go down to atlantic
city home of the great harry hurley
and say hello to eddie eddie hello
is eddie there
he's gone
all right let's try gary in east haven
are you there gary uh how you doing bob
hey jim it's great to hear you on the
radio again
thanks uh hey jim you know
i don't want to give bob a hard time but
um he likes to hang up on people who
mention the illuminati now according to
your studies wouldn't you say that the
illuminati
or at least the illuminati is visible in
these front organizations such as the
council of foreign relations the
bilderbergers and the trilaterals
well uh yeah in my study for rule by
secrecy if you'll track all that back
you'll find that a lot of the
programs that these societies are
pushing such as a graduated income tax a
you know
a lot of things
basically can be found and tracked back
to the
karl marx and his communist manifesto
which seemed to be almost a verbatim
recitation of the goals of the bavarian
illuminati
all right uh thank you very much gary i
wasn't aware that as soon as you mention
illuminati i hang up i'll have to
remember that i've got to remember that
pavlov's dog where are you i mean my
heavens you mentioned illuminati hangs
up
uh
you know you said something about karl
marx
now karl marx seems to be the antithesis
of uh david rockefeller or any of the
other magnets
capitalists of the world that's that's
been one of the mysteries and the thing
that's thrown so many off during the
20th century is that
you know while you know even uh senator
mccarthy kept talking about the
communist in the state department well
he didn't quite understand that the
state department since world war ii had
been just filled with council on foreign
relations people and that back into the
1900s you find the very people who
created the council on foreign relations
were the very same people who created
communism
when lenin when the russian revolution
broke out in 1917
linen wasn't there was he he was in
switzerland and he was aided back into
russia by the german high command and
and on this famous seal railroad car and
by one max warburg who was head of the
german central bank and a ranking member
of german intelligence and what people
didn't understand was that his brother
paul warburg helped found the federal
reserve system in this country and was
in charge of war bond sales during world
war one so you got the two brothers on
both sides what's with that and lenin
then goes into russia takes over the
revolution creates communism with money
and funding trotsky was in new york he
sent off with thousands of dollars from
wall street capitalist why would they be
giving money to the communists since
they vowed to destroy capitalism well
lenin said
we will hang the capitalists with the
rope he will sell us let's take one
final quick break
a presentation
yes
okay
um
thirty
[Music]
we'll have time for one i think one
quick all these things help make your
world a safer and better place to live
as well as making you a better person
click on weprevent.org
to find out what you can do a public
service message the us department of
justice the crime prevention coalition
of america and the ad council
do all your programs go this fast
no
because usually i suffer alone
all right ladies and gentlemen we're
going to conclude with a call from bill
in the car are you there bill
yes i am bob go ahead uh just one i'm a
pass master been a freemason for near 30
years
and uh my statement was why we are
so-called secret if everybody remembers
when the nazis in world war ii
in preceding that time hitler was
annihilating them but they survived
they had forget-me-not plants they would
plant in a home and they would have a
meeting there and they survived through
the holocaust through the nazis and
continued on
and i find it pretty interesting that he
would find that
part of a international group to
conspire to world domination i really
find that interesting
well i think you've misconstrued what
i've said let me say for about the
sixth time now that most masons in this
country are fine upstanding honest
people okay what i'm saying is is it's
been through freemasonry that some of
these secrets and some of this hidden
knowledge has been passed along down
through the centuries i'd also like to
just kind of wrap up here with a quote
from the english philosopher herbert
spencer
who said there is a principle which is a
bar against all information which is
proof against all arguments and which
cannot fail to keep a man in everlasting
ignorance and that principle is contempt
prior to investigation
so in other words uh i don't expect
anybody to believe me and i certainly
don't expect them to trust me but if you
will study the material if you'll read
rude by secrecy and think about it maybe
it will point us the way
jim mars i've enjoyed your visit i hope
our audience has too thank you very much
sir
[Music]
jim mars is a journalist living in texas
his new book rule by secrecy is
published by harper collins mr mars is
the author of two previous books alien
agenda which is about ufos and
extraterrestrial beings and crossfire
about president kennedy's assassination
[Music]
48 hours